foreign
ER for you all right I just figured it's
something that people think they know
about but it really don't okay so
I just thought I would sort of bring it
up and it has to do with tire pressure
tire pressure tire pressure tired okay
all right all right all right okay are
you ready I'm really not ready
but this is
um you know where Hey listen I feel like
this at this point
you know uh with them paddled out it's
time to ride the wave that's the way I
feel we're out there just let's do it
bring it on here you bring tire pressure
I'm like it's you got to be Zen enough
to go ahead and jump up it's time to get
up and and surf this wave that's all all
right let's do it so tire pressure first
of all if you have a tire with quote no
air in it
of course there's air in it because
there's the atmospheric air is in it
right okay and atmosphere has its own
pressure and this is the weight of a
column of air
from Earth's surface all the way up to
the edge of the atmosphere if you had
found a way to weigh this we I think we
might have talked about this in another
explainer but if you if you have like
one square inch or one square anything
but one square inch and have weigh that
column of air it will weigh 14.7 pounds
nice okay and the way air Works fluids
work is that pressure I would say yes
it's sitting on the scale but that
pressure manifests in every direction
because the molecules are vibrating in
every direction right so so right now I
have 14.7 pounds per square inch on one
side of my hand and on the other side
above above and below and so
everything's all equal now every
direction so I don't even notice it like
you're not getting crushed by your 14
pound air wreck it doesn't make a
difference correct pushing down on you
and pushing up and pushing up it's even
Steven whereas if I have a suction cup
right and I press out the air that would
otherwise eyes be balancing it
if I press it out yeah so now I say lift
up the suction cup because I can't it's
sucking me down no it's not
why can't you pick up like seven pounds
per square inch per square
putting it down pushing it it's really
not sucking anything yes suction cups
don't suck they don't suck wait they got
a bad rap but still alive they don't
suck they don't suck
so if you had 10 square inches of area
on this on the suction cup right I can
ask you how much force would it take to
pull the suction cup off the surface so
I gotta go 10 square inches times 14.7
pounds per and then push back in that
opposite direction and okay that gets
you 147 pounds so if you can pull 147
pounds or more it pops right off or you
could cheat and pop open a little uh
Pearl in the edge and and then let the
nature do it for you air slips in and
then it just comes on right then you let
nature help you out okay so the point is
if you fill a tire to what we call 10
pounds per square inch that's 10 pounds
on top of the air pressure that's
already in there right that's all I'm
saying right all right so first of all
just lay that out cool so now have you
noticed or perhaps not
that on bicycle tires the thinner the
skinnier the tube yes
the what
the less air you should keep putting in
it once it gets hard because it will pop
I'm telling you okay but from experience
okay
okay if you look at the ratings of thin
tires
in essentially every case depending what
they're made of but in every case they
have a higher pounds per square inch
rating than the bigger tires
okay hi okay
I don't I didn't know that to be honest
yes yes okay this is the first I'm ever
hearing of this okay because you never
got to pay attention well no I'm gonna
tell you why
because I come from the times when you
will feel your tire and then you just
push down on it and if you can actually
push it and flatten it you're like now
put some more air in there okay oh that
was how you measure it yeah and then
once you couldn't do that you'd be like
all right it's time to go this time yeah
yeah you want to use a gauge okay right
exactly right all right so and the cage
is calibrated to not count air pressure
all right so that's how they work all
right so now watch you sitting on your
bicycle
and the bicycle has tires and the tires
are in contact with the road
obviously the heavier you heavier you
are the flatter the tire is going to
look true okay we that okay you know
this well yeah why does the tire flatten
if you're heavier why why does it do
that I'm going to tell you why because
at all times
the pressure inside the tire
per square inch
times the square inches of Tire in
contact with the road
has to equal your weight plus the weight
of the bicycle
at all times at all times okay
Okay so
okay so all right so if I have a big
time like a kid's Tire okay if I have
one of those kind of tires and it's huge
it might take 30 pounds per square inch
that's not uncommon okay 30 20 to 30
pounds per square inch
and there's a square inch of it in
contact in the back and a square inch in
contact with the front add those up it
is holding up 60 pounds
that could be the weight of the bicycle
plus the weight of the kit okay you put
a heavy hit on there
the bicycle has to hold up more weight
against the air pressure in the tires so
the the tires flatten a little more
adding more surface area right okay
adding more area so that now you go go
the air pressure times the the square
inches in touch with the ground and now
that'll equal the weight of the heavier
kid okay so I I'm heavy all right I'm
260 pounds right now
okay okay all right so now
I ride a bicycle with very narrow tires
the air pressure in those tires is 130
pounds per square inch
130 pounds okay per tire
so Watch What Happens I I deflate it to
that amount and those tires will flatten
to slightly more than a square inch per
tire
because it's my weight plus the weight
of the 22 pound bicycle it's got to hold
up 280 pounds
right so it's going to flatten slightly
more than a square inch on each and that
is my that is my tire
okay okay so
so
farm tractors
have huge tires right huge tires
in that way they put relatively low air
pressure in them
that way when the tires roll over the
crops ah it does minimal damage right
because you're not digging in you're not
digging you don't need that that's out
that's the pressure brilliant okay you
can still hold up the tractor right if
you if you get enough area coming down
otherwise you'd be leaving deep tracks
in the road and you can't have that not
in yourself it's like dune buggies they
all have big giant wide like balloon
tires well that one is to increase
traction on Sand yeah because they don't
dig into the sand is what I'm saying
they don't dig into the sand correct and
so so tire pressure is all about how
much weight are you holding up and they
will tell you in your car if you're
gonna carry a heavy load increase the
air pressure in your tires so that your
tires don't flatten out right okay if
you increase the pressure from let's say
uh you know 35 pounds to 45 pounds per
square inch that gets you extra support
in all of your tires in a typical car
you know how wide is it is a tire you
know it might be a foot you know 20 18
inches is a typical tire no no not
across yeah what are you doing riding
the Indy 500 what
18 inches yeah okay all right I'll give
it to you I don't know I mean we're both
City people so I don't you know well
yeah I mean I I drive an SUV though
okay you said car and I'm I'm really not
thinking SUV okay yeah fine okay so a
car might be and it's not electric and
I'm very ashamed but I'm buying an
electric car so I know you already have
one eventually I'm late to the game so
here's what you do you can do this
experiment at home please go look at how
much of your tire is touching the ground
measure that okay front to back and then
across the width so you'll get two
measurements it might be like five
inches uh front to back flattening on
the ground and then measure the the
width of the tire multiply those numbers
by each other that's the square inches
per tire multiply that by four and
that's going to give you the weight of
your car
get out of here yes that's pretty wild I
mean that makes sense just from what you
just said correct uh there's only one
problem what's that I did not give a
damn how much my car weighs
[Laughter]
where between you're an SUV somewhere
between 1500 pounds and a ton 2 000
something like that that makes sense but
all just by measuring the square inches
so oh sorry you have to know what your
tire pressure is first right okay
it's in the side Pole or or maybe if
you're a modern car it tells you yeah
they can tell you on the dashboard on
the dashboard and so you got four tires
and get the area so it's front to back
in contact and then the width multiply
those two numbers then multiply by four
and multiply by your air pressure that's
the way that's the weight of your car
and so you it's a way to weigh your car
without going to a scale that's pretty
cool your tires are doing it all by
themselves and now uh all I need to do
is figure out the calculation to
um put uh Aunt Gail and uncle Daryl in
the back seat
um that's a different calculation so
it'll either flatten the tires some more
believe me
so then the car has given itself a way
to hold them up or you increase the air
pressure so that at the same area in
contact with the ground it holds them up
that's what okay that's sweet and
generally they tell you to increase the
air pressure because it's better for gas
mileage and things right yeah all right
you got it dude that's cool but there's
mass in everything it really is I gotta
tell you I
I was worried when you said tire
pressure okay I really will I was
worried man
so just just a quick one a quick one
doesn't belong in this explainer at all
but while we're here do you know your
hat size I don't you don't okay uh I
know it's small though it's like seven
it's a seven or six that wouldn't be
small if it's seven it wouldn't be small
okay
so here's what you do measure get a tape
measure and measure the circumference of
your head
in inches okay right where the brim
would sit all right okay write down that
number and then divide it by pi that's
your hat size
okay
I'm definitely going to do that okay
I can't wait to get this over with
because that's a damn that's the first
thing I'm gonna do as soon as we get off
this call there's measurements and
everything
yeah in inches where the brim will sit
right and
um divided by pi correct and that's your
hat size it'll fit perfectly every time
that's
that's pretty cool there are two very
good things I've learned right now
that's probably your head size in
America elsewhere I don't know how they
do it well don't worry because I'm not
buying a hat from any place but America
okay damn right
in the way ahead make sure my American
hat is made in China that's right the
way you pulling off my hat says me in
China
pull up my hat and it'll say make
America hat again
make America hat again and boom I am
right
baby what the hell I'm that's what I'm
talking
about this is evidence it's time to end
this explainer okay it's been he had
another Star Talk explainer Chuck thanks
for being there always a pleasure all
right Neil deGrasse Tyson keep looking
up
foreign
[Music]